after 12 years Kristen Bell is back as
Veronica Mars and I got the celebration
started on set can I give you a little
gift we were on the set oh my god the
first time I know our each about to make
how many back links of the year that can
one person have Oh Bob a lot of hair
lengths when I first read the script I
thought this is some of the best stuff
I've ever read where you time right we
don't know they're talking about by far
the best pilot I'd read and immediately
when I read it I knew that you had only
read two pilots I would pester these
people until I got the part
oh my god the best pilot I ever read
because I had only read to five we love
how Kristin keeps it real something
she's been doing since landing the role
of teen sleuths Veronica Mars in 2004
little girls need role models like this
to know that they can have an opinion
about things I'm not proud of anything
than having been a part of this role
that my daughter's will see one day
because Veronica knows how to act in the
world yes indeed the season for revival
is an eight part Hulu miniseries that
has Veronica tracking down a serial
bomber in her town of Neptune and
Kristen is already down to do a season
five I will play this character well
into the Murder She Wrote years till
everyone in Neptune
[Music]